This is 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars. Americans have always had an uneasy relationship with gambling. To circumvent anti-gambling laws in the US, early slot machines masqueraded as vending machines. Or a trade machine as they were called. And the symbols on the machine had to obscure its true intent. So you'd have these fruit symbols of cherries and lemons and oranges on the reels and they would offer prizes Like chewing gum or other treats. That you would then have to redeem for cash. Like tickets at Chuck E. Cheese. So it was almost like laundering it back into money.
这里是 99% Invisible。我是罗曼·马尔斯。美国人对赌博一直抱有一种复杂微妙的关系。为了绕过美国的反赌博法，早期的老虎机伪装成自动售货机，或者当时所谓的贸易机。机器上的符号必须掩盖其真实意图。所以卷轴上会有樱桃、柠檬和橙子这样的水果符号，它们会提供口香糖或其他奖品之类的奖励，然后你需要把这些奖励兑换成现金，就像查奇芝士餐厅（Chuck E. Cheese）里的彩票一样。所以这几乎就像是把东西洗白成钱。
Many slot machines have retained the fruit symbols to this day. Heck in the UK they're actually called fruit machines because of this. So that is a carryover from that era. The new universal bar symbol, which I always thought represented, stacks of bars of gold, has a similar origin. The bar symbol is actually based on the logo of the Bell Fruit Gum Company. I'm talking with Natasha Dao Shoe. My name is Natasha Daushel and I'm an associate professor at MIT and the title of my book
许多老虎机至今仍保留着水果符号。见鬼，在英国，它们甚至因此被称为“水果机”。所以这是那个时代的遗留产物。现在通用的条形（bar）符号——我以前一直以为它代表一叠叠金条——也有着类似的起源。条形符号实际上是基于贝尔水果口香糖公司（Bell Fruit Gum Company）的标志。我正在与娜塔莎·多舒（Natasha Dow Schüll）交谈。我叫娜塔莎·多舒，我是麻省理工学院的一名副教授，我的书名是
is Addiction by Design. All about machine gambling in Las Vegas. You can probably picture a slot machine pretty easily. The image we have that we carry around in our minds of the slot machine. It's pretty much the same machine that came out in 1895. Three wheels, mechanical wheels that spin, and you are playing to line up symbols across one line. So one bar of symbols.
（Addiction by Design），全书都在探讨拉斯维加斯的机器赌博。你大概能很轻松地想象出一个老虎机。我们脑海中对老虎机的固有印象，其实和 1895 年问世的第一台机器几乎一模一样。三个轮子，会旋转的机械轮，而你玩的目的是在一条线上对齐符号，也就是一排符号。
And to get the machine to play, you're putting in coins, and then you're reaching up with your arm and pulling this lever. So it's a very mechanical interaction. This is the famous one-armed bandit. Today, if you walk into a casino, you may still see those levers, but they have a new name, Legacy Lovers. Because they're basically just there
为了让机器运转，你要投入硬币，然后伸手拉动这个杠杆。所以这是一种非常机械化的交互。这就是著名的“单臂强盗”。今天，如果你走进赌场，你可能仍然会看到那些杠杆，但它们有了一个新名字：遗产杠杆（Legacy Levers）。因为它们基本上只是用来
to evoke that bygone mechanical machine and to attract us over, we recognize it, we can pull the lever, but we very quickly realize after sitting down that it's a lot faster and more efficient and ultimately less fatiguing if we're sitting there for a while to press the buttons or in some cases to touch the screen. A classic skewomorph. The physical machine, the hardware that you're interacting with, has really shifted. Skewomorphs are design elements that are retained as an ornament past the point where they serve any meaningful function.
唤起人们对那个逝去的机械时代的记忆，吸引我们过去。我们认得它，我们可以拉动杠杆，但坐下来后我们很快就会发现，如果我们要在那儿坐上一段时间，去按按钮（或者在某些情况下触摸屏幕）要快得多、高效得多，而且最终不那么累。一个经典的拟态（skeuomorph）。你与之交互的物理机器和硬件实际上已经发生了变化。拟态是指那些作为装饰保留下来、早已失去任何实质功能的 设计元素。
Slot machines are skewomorphic champions. They're lousy with design elements that make you feel like you're interacting with a trustworthy mechanical objects. And it's not just the legacy lovers. It's also the screen you're looking at. So this is typically now a video screen rather than a mechanical three-reel setup. Some of these video machines, however, try to make us think we're playing a mechanical machine. They sort of have a kind of analog, kachink, kachink to them. Military visual mapping technology is used.
老虎机堪称拟态设计的冠军。它们充斥着各种设计元素，让你感觉自己是在和一个值得信赖的机械物体交互。不仅是那些遗产杠杆，还有你正在看的屏幕。现在这通常是一个视频屏幕，而不是机械的三轮结构。然而，其中一些视频机器试图让我们以为我们在玩一台机械机器。它们自带某种模拟的“咔嚓、咔嚓”的声音。这里运用了军事视觉映射技术。
It's like this three-layer plasma screen. So there are actual real spinning, they're blank, and what's happening is there's a video projection onto them. So it's not like they're marked with actual symbols. The symbols that appear can just be changed up. So there's lots of little tricks by which designers try to get us to feel that we are still playing an analog mechanical device. According to CBS News, Americans now spend more money on slot machines than movies, baseball and theme parks combined. But this wasn't always the case.
它就像这种三层的等离子屏幕。所以其实有真正的旋转部分，它们是空白的，实际发生的是视频投影到它们上面。所以它们并不是印有实际符号。出现的符号是可以随时改变的。因此，设计师用了很多小把戏，让我们觉得我们仍然在玩一个模拟的机械设备。据 CBS 新闻报道，美国人现在在老虎机上花的钱，比电影、棒球和主题公园加起来还要多。但情况并非一直如此。
These were seen as really just frivolous little devices that were there to occupy the wives of the real gamblers or to occupy people in these sort of transitional spaces while they were waiting online or in hallways or around the fringes of the main gambling pit. So they didn't tend to have stools much less the precise ergonomic seeding that they have today. They weren't destinations. They were really transitional devices.
过去，这些设备真的只被视为微不足道的小玩意儿，用来打发真正赌客的太太们，或者让人们在排队、走廊里或主赌场边缘等过渡空间里消磨时间。所以它们往往没有凳子，更不用说像今天这样精确符合人体工学的座椅了。它们不是目的地，它们真的只是过渡性的设备。
But not anymore. And then there is this historical association in this country between women, particularly older women nowadays, and these slot machines. So in every way these machines are thought of as being light, a light form of gambling. And the real irony there is that these machines that anyone can be very approachable, you don't have to know the rules, you have to be wearing a suit, or interact with other people in some intimidating way. The irony is that they are the most potent, if you want to use that word, in terms of how addicting they are. It's been shown that you get problematically involved with these devices,
但今时不同往日了。在这个国家，女性（尤其是现在的年长女性）和这些老虎机之间存在着一种历史上的联系。所以在方方面面，这些机器都被认为是一种轻量级的赌博形式。这里真正的讽刺之处在于，这些任何人都能玩、非常平易近人的机器——你不需要懂规则，不需要穿西装，也不需要以某种吓人的方式与其他人互动——最讽刺的是，如果你想用这个词的话，它们在让人上瘾的程度上是最强效的。事实证明，你会陷入这些设备带来的问题中，
three to four times faster than you would at the racetrack or playing card games. Problematically involved is my new favorite euphemism. Despite the slot machines very familiar appearance, this is a device that has evolved dramatically with one goal in mind to keep you playing that machine. We often think, especially people who don't play these machines, the assumption is people must be playing these machines, especially the people who play them a lot
其速度是在赛马场或玩纸牌游戏时的三到四倍。“陷入问题中”是我目前最喜欢的委婉说法。尽管老虎机的外观非常眼熟，但这其实是一个经历了戏剧性演变的设备，其唯一的目的就是让你一直玩下去。我们经常认为——特别是那些不玩这些机器的人——会想当然地觉得，玩这些机器的人，尤其是那些经常玩的人，
because they want to win. And these are sort of dupes. These are poor people who don't understand how probability works. They're not rational. If only they could be educated, they'd make these proper consumer decisions. But in fact, if you talk to a lot of these gamblers, they are incredibly savvy. They're not doops. They know they're not going to win, and they know that if they do win a jackpot, that means they'll just sit there longer and play it off. So it's not really about winning. It's about getting into the zone. Everything else falls away, a sense of monetary value, time, space, even a sense of self is annihilated in the extreme form of this zone that you enter.
是因为他们想赢。这些人就像是被骗了。他们是些不懂概率是如何运作的穷人。他们是不理性的。要是能接受教育，他们就会做出正确的消费决策。但事实上，如果你和这些赌客交谈，你会发现他们极其精明。他们才不是白痴。他们知道自己不会赢，也知道如果真的中了头奖，那就意味着他们得在机器前坐更长时间，把钱全输进去。所以这根本不是为了赢。这纯粹是为了进入“心流状态”（the zone）。其他一切都烟消云散了：对金钱价值、时间、空间的概念，甚至连自我意识都在你进入的这种极致状态中被抹去了。
There was one moment in Shul's research where the whole concept of the zone really sunk in for her. She was talking with a gambler. And she said, you know, sometimes I have to say I get this sense of frustration and irritation when I win a jackpot. Because it just freezes up my flow. I just want to continue playing. I've witnessed this in a casino. The player wins, and as the credits are accruing,
在多舒的研究中，有一个时刻让她真正深刻理解了“心流状态”这个概念。当时她正在和一个赌客交谈。对方说：“你知道吗，有时候我不得不说，当我中头奖时，我会产生一种挫败感和烦躁感。因为这打断了我的节奏。我只想继续玩下去。”我在赌场里亲眼目睹过这一点。玩家赢了，随着彩分不断累积，
ding, ding, ding, ding, ding, they're just continuing to bang that spin button. They just can't wait to hit it again. So there's this design imperative to overcome the problem of interruption, a design imperative to overcome the player's problem with winning. And you know, the gambling industry has its own way of freezing this. They're aware
叮、叮、叮、叮、叮，他们还在不停地猛拍旋转按钮。他们简直迫不及待地想再次按下它。因此，这里存在着一种设计上的必然要求，即克服被打断的问题，克服玩家因获胜而产生的问题。你知道的，赌博行业有他们自己的一套方式来解决这个问题。他们意识到了
of this zone. Sometimes they call it a zone. They also have a term that there are played win players or jackpot players. And then there's played a win to play players. Otherwise known as time on device players. And Shul's book tracks this sea change in the gambling industry away from jackpot play and towards time on device play. So this is not play where you go in and you're excited and you're out to get this euphoric thrill from a big win. Or from the industry side, you're not out to sort of flee someone and take all their money right away and then get them off the machine so you can take someone else's money. This is more about profit from volume. The idea is that gamblers want to sit there longer and the industry has realized profit really
这种“心流状态”的存在。有时他们称之为“心流状态”。他们还有一个术语，叫做“为赢而玩”的玩家或“头奖玩家”。然后是“为玩而赢”的玩家。也就是所谓的“游戏时间”玩家。多舒的书记录了赌博行业的这一巨变：从追求头奖的玩法转向追求游戏时间的玩法。所以，这并不是那种你兴高采烈地走进去，一心想从大奖中获得欣快感的玩法；从行业的角度来看，你也不是为了敲诈某人，一下子拿走他们所有的钱，然后让他们离开机器，好去赚另一个人的钱。这更多的是关于通过量来获利。其理念是赌客们想坐在那儿更长时间，而行业已经意识到，利润
isn't about the price of play, it's about the volume of play. And once you understand that, it begins to make a lot more sense why penny machines, machines played with the denomination of one cent are generating higher profits than any other machine today. Now, if you had asked the industry a decade ago what's going to become of penny machines, they would have laughed at you because at that stage, even nickel machines were considered, they were really mocked as games you'd only find in grind joints. But if we look closely at some technological advances, that certain makers have hit upon,
其实不在于玩一次的价格，而在于玩的总量。一旦你明白了这一点，就很容易理解为什么面值一美分的“一分钱机器”能产生比当今任何其他机器更高的利润。现在，如果你在十年前问业内人士一分钱机器会怎么样，他们会嘲笑你，因为在那个阶段，连五分钱机器都被认为是只能在低档赌博场所找到的笑柄。但如果我们仔细观察某些制造商取得的技术突破，
they started to realize, aha, if we take the bet and we break it down into pennies and find ways with the computer algorithms inside the machine to extend betting over a longer period we can ultimately make more money. So the lights in the sound attract you. The casino atmospheric draw you in. The ergonomic seats keep you comfortable. The max of bet and spin buttons don't even require you to move your hand from its resting position. The max bet and spin buttons don't even require you to move your hand from its resting position. The recess screen pulls you into your own private world and you enter the zone.
他们开始意识到，啊哈！如果我们把赌注拆解成一分钱，并通过机器内部的计算机算法找到延长赌博时间的方法，我们最终就能赚到更多的钱。所以灯光和声音吸引你。赌场的氛围吸引你。符合人体工学座椅让你保持舒适。最大下注和旋转按钮甚至不需要你把手从放置的位置移开。最大下注和旋转按钮甚至不需要你从放置的位置移开。凹陷的屏幕将你拉入你自己的私人世界，你进入了心流状态。
But what's going to keep you playing is the math and that's really the revolution of these new video slots. And the math, and that's the term the industry uses, has gotten very complicated. So if you imagine our friend, the old one, are abandoned, you had these three reels with symbols on them, and you were betting on lining up one single line of symbols across. Now, even on mechanical machines designers quickly
但能让你继续玩下去的是数学，这才是这些新型视频老虎机的真正革命所在。“数学”——这是业内使用的术语——已经变得非常复杂。所以如果你想象我们熟悉的老朋友“单臂强盗”，它有三个带符号的轮子，你下注是为了在中间连成单独的一条符号线。现在，即使在机械机器上，设计师也很快
found creative ways to add in other lines of play. So usually when you see these reels you can sort of see the line above and the line below. The genius of showing extra lines above and below the winning line is that it introduces the near-miss phenomenon. It's that feeling that you almost won when you see that winning symbol so close on that adjacent line. But the extra lines are also available for placing extra bets. So the idea was let's let people bet on three lines and let them bet instead of, you know, one token, they can bet two tokens on two lines or three. So you did see these early multi-coin games, but there was limits to them because there's really a limit when you're talking about mechanical reels to how many
想出了创造性的方法来加入其他的游戏线。所以通常当你看到这些卷轴时，你大概能看到上面的一行和下面的一行。在赢钱行的上下展示额外行的天才之处在于，它引入了“差点赢”（near-miss）的现象。当你看到那个赢钱符号在相邻的线上离得那么近时，你就会产生一种“我差一点就赢了”的感觉。但这些额外的线也可以用来下额外的注。所以当时的设想是，让人们在三条线上下注，让他们不用下注一个代币，而是可以在两行或三行上分别下注两个代币。所以你确实看到了这些早期的多币种游戏，但它们是有限制的，因为说到机械卷轴，你能塞进屏幕的
symbols you can fit on the screen. But then video technology came along and slot machines could do whatever the designer wanted. So you started seeing this progression from not just lines, you know, you had even your two diagonals from the corners of the screen down. Then you started seeing, well, let's add extra reels. Let's add five, six, seven reels across. And let's add extra reels. Let's add five, six, seven reels across. And let's add zigzags and weird directions.
符号数量确实是有限的。但随后视频技术出现了，老虎机可以随心所欲地做设计师想要的任何事。于是你开始看到这种演变：不仅仅是连线，你甚至有了从屏幕角落向下的两条对角线。然后你开始看到，好吧，让我们增加额外的卷轴。让我们横向增加五个、六个、七个卷轴。让我们横向增加五个、六个、七个卷轴。让我们加入之字形和奇怪的方向。
So it's typical today to see 20, 50, 100 line games. And it gets so complicated it begins to get really hard to tell if you even one or not, the on-screen graphics have to draw the lines for you. Some machines have even gone so far as to do away with lining up altogether. They have what's called scatter play, so it's really quite random. You're no longer playing to line up that one line of symbols across. Which is insane!
所以今天看到 20 线、50 线、100 线的游戏是很常见的。而且它变得如此复杂，以至于你甚至很难分清自己到底赢没赢，屏幕上的图形不得不为你画出连线。有些机器甚至走得更远，彻底取消了连线机制。它们有所谓的“分散下注”（scatter play），所以这其实相当随机。你不再是为了在一条线上对齐符号而玩。这太疯狂了！
So that's all going on. You say, well, what's going on here? What's significant about that is that if you're playing on a penny machine, you decide that you're going to bet a penny per line. So that would be 100 pennies. That's a dollar. In fact, you can max it out and bet, you know,
所以这一切都在发生。你会说，这到底是怎么回事？这里的重要之处在于，如果你在一台一分钱机器上玩，你决定每条线下一分钱。那么这就是 100 分。也就是一美元。事实上，你可以把赌注拉满，下注，你知道的，
three pennies per line. So in fact, you're making $3 a bet. That's quite significant. You know, when quarter players started disappearing, when video slots came out, researchers were sent onto Casino floors to find out where did our, where are quarter players going? Are they migrating to dollars as we thought they would? No, they were kind of regressing back to nickel machines, but in the end, they were actually paying more, they were betting more per hand than they had on the quarter machines. So the question is why would a gambler do that?
每条线三分。所以实际上，你每下一注就是 3 美元。这相当可观。你知道，当 25 美分（quarter）硬币玩家开始消失、视频老虎机问世时，研究人员被派往赌场大厅，去查明我们的 25 美分玩家都去哪儿了？他们像我们想象的那样转向一美元面值了吗？没有，他们有点退回到五分钱机器，但最终，他们实际花的钱、每手下的注，其实比在 25 美分机器上还要多。所以问题是，为什么赌客会这么做？
The slots aren't more appealing because they take more coins. Here's the real trick. When you're betting 300 pennies on 100 lines, you're going to win back a portion of those. For the first time in history, you're not betting a token and then losing it all or doubling it, tripling it. That's a really volatile setup. This is much less volatile.
老虎机之所以更有吸引力，并不是因为它们消耗的硬币更多。这里面真正的诀窍在于：当你在一百条线上押注 300 分时，你会赢回一部分。这是历史上头一次，你下的不是一个孤注一掷、要么全输要么翻倍或三倍的代币。那是一种波动性极大的设置。而这种设置的波动性要小得多。
You're spreading your bet across 100 lines and it's really a lot safer if you wanna see it that way. Because chances are you're gonna win back something on some of those lines. lines, and it's really a lot safer if you want to see it that way, because chances are you're going to win back something on some of those lines. And it just so happens that these machines are designed when you win back something, to give you all the winning stimuli that comes along with a real win. And so one researcher has aptly called this a false win, or losses disguised as wins, because you're putting in 45 coins, you're winning, quote, unquote,
你将赌注分散在 100 条线上，如果你这样看待它的话，其实要安全得多。因为你很有可能会在其中一些线上赢回一些东西。线，如果你这样看待它的话，其实要安全得多，因为你很有可能会在其中一些线上赢回一些东西。而这些机器的设计恰好是，当你赢回一些东西时，会给你带来伴随真正赢钱而来的所有赢钱刺激。因此，一位研究人员恰如其分地称之为“假赢”或者“伪装成赢的输”，因为你投入了 45 个硬币，你赢了，也就是所谓的
winning nine back. That's a pretty radical net loss. But yet, there's little ditties that are being played. It's virtually no different than when you really do win. Another key factor in making penny machines possible in all their little microbeats are updates on how the player feeds money into the machine. Yeah, this is a huge part of it alongside the ergonomics of the chairs
赢回 9 个。这是一个相当极端的净亏损。然而，机器还在播放着小曲子。这实际上和真正赢钱时没有任何区别。使一分钱机器及其所有微型下注成为可能的另一个关键因素，是玩家向机器投币方式的更新。是的，这是其中巨大的一部分，与椅子的工效学设计、
and the changes in the responsibility of the buttons and how they're placed came the financial access technology. And, you know, if you think about the past, if you ran out of money and you wanted to continue to play at a machine, there was a lot of steps you had to, you really had to work for it. You had to leave your machine, maybe wouldn't be there when you got back, ask someone to hold it, and then go off and search of an ATM, get some cash. Then you had to search
按钮职责及其放置位置的变化齐头并进的，是金融接入技术。而且，如果你想想过去，如果你钱花光了，想继续在一台机器上玩，你得经历很多步骤，你真的得为此付出劳动。你得离开你的机器，等你回来时它可能已经不在了，你得请别人帮你看一会儿，然后去找一台 ATM 机取点现金。接着你还得去找
out a cashier's cage or a roving chain detending by these coins, return to a machine, open the coins, and put them in one by one. That was very labor intensive. And then imagine feeding in 300 pennies. So you started seeing bill acceptors. It would take $20. It was sort of a move to credit play. And with the bill acceptors, you got these little digital monitors where it wasn't exactly telling you how much money was in the machine. It was telling you how many credits. So already there with bill acceptors, you saw kind of turn toward credit play, which
一个出纳柜台，或者找一个带着这些硬币的流动零钱兑换员，回到机器旁，打开硬币槽，一枚一枚地投进去。这非常耗费体力。然后想象一下投进 300 个一分钱。于是你开始看到纸币接收器。它可以接收 20 美元。这算是向信用额度玩的转变。有了纸币接收器，你就会看到这些小型数字显示器，它们不一定会告诉你机器里有多少钱，而是告诉你还有多少信用分。所以早在纸币接收器时代，你就能看到向信用玩的转变，这
really dematerialized the money, made it less real somehow, and allowed you to get in that zone, you know, disconnected you again from the everyday world. Nowadays a lot of machine gambling uses these player reward cards. Which are essentially credit cards that the casino sets up for you, where you store credit, you'll often go into a casino and see people, they're seemingly connected to these machines, almost like life support with these plastic bungee cords that are attached to their cards, they won't forget them and lose them there. So you'll look down a whole line and everyone's sort of attached to these machines with these plastic ropes. But ticket in, ticket out technology,
确实使金钱失去了实体感，在某种程度上让它变得不那么真实，并让你能够进入那种“心流状态”，你知道的，它再次让你与日常生活世界脱节。如今，许多机器赌博都使用这些玩家奖励卡。它们本质上是赌场为你开立的信用卡，你可以在上面存储积分。你经常走进赌场，看到人们似乎与这些机器连为一体，就像戴着生命维持系统一样，他们的卡上连着塑料弹力绳，这样他们就不会忘记并把卡丢在那里。所以你会顺着一整排看过去，每个人都用这些塑料绳挂在这些机器上。但是“存票、取票”技术——
where you're playing with these barcoded tickets and player cards were really necessary piece of the technological puzzle for pennies to come on the scene in the way that they did with multi-line machines. And this design evolution is the reason why slot machines are the most profitable form of gambling, even though there is no skill involved, and the player doesn't even know the odds of winning for any given machine. One gambler in my book Rose, who said, you know, I became a slot machine technician to understand more about these machines, and I thought it would be a good part of my recovery
即使用带有条形码的票据和玩家卡进行游戏——确实是技术拼图中的一个必要部分，才让一分钱机器能够以多线机器那种方式登上历史舞台。这种设计的演变正是老虎机成为最赚钱的赌博形式的原因，尽管其中不涉及任何技巧，而且玩家甚至不知道任何特定机器的赢面概率。我书中的一位赌客罗斯说：“你知道的，我成了一名老虎机技术员，以便更多地了解这些机器，我以为这对我戒除
from the addiction, because I thought if I understand how these machines work the spell will be broken and she said you know even after I was putting these machines together and designing them at work. On my lunch breaks I would just go down the street and play the exact same machines. Because that is how addiction works. 99% in visible is Sam Greenspan and me Roman Mars, we're a project of 91.7 local public radio KALW in San Francisco and the American Institute of Architects in San Francisco. You can find the show and like the show on Facebook, I tweet at Roman Mars but we'll have more info about Shul's really great book addiction by design and her film about all you can eat Vegas by face.
成瘾会有所帮助，因为我想如果我了解了这些机器是如何运作的，这个魔咒就会被打破。”但她说：“你知道，即使在我亲手组装和设计这些机器之后，在午休时间，我还是会走到街上去玩完全相同的机器。”因为成瘾就是这样的运作方式。99% Invisible 的制作人员有山姆·格林斯潘（Sam Greenspan）和我罗曼·马尔斯。我们是旧金山本地公共电台 KALW 91.7 以及旧金山美国建筑师学会的项目。你可以在 Facebook 上找到并关注这个节目，我在推特上叫 @RomanMars。关于多舒非常棒的书《设计成瘾》以及她关于拉斯维加斯“无限畅吃”纪录片的更多信息，
Oh my god. At our website 99%invisible.org. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
天哪。请访问我们的网站 99%invisible.org。本集暂时还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可留下评论。